>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Roberta Shaffer:
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Roberta Shaffer and it's
my pleasure to welcome you on behalf
of Jane Sanchez, the Law
Librarian of Congress who is unable
to join us this morning,
but sent me,
her Special Advisor, in her stead.
We're really delighted to be hosting
this program which is, I think,
becoming part of a series of events
in which we are commemorating
and continuing to learn from the
experience of the Venetian Ghetto,
so this 500-year trajectory of
learning continues this morning.
We had a program last spring.
Today is a full day of
learning for all of us.
We have a phenomenal
display of the Library
of Congress collections relating to
Hebraic Publishing during the time
of the Ghetto as well as
other related documents.
This afternoon at 2 o'clock
we will be showing a film.
It's a documentary
about the Venice Ghetto.
And then we will again celebrate
the Venice Ghetto with a re-appeal,
a mock appeal, of the Shylock
trial from The Merchant
of Venice on June 21st
in the late afternoon
and the presiding justice
will be Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
So I hope that you will all
be marking your iPhones now
and will be able to
join us at that time.
There is debate, as many of
you know, about the term,
the derivation of the term "ghetto."
We do believe that it was first
used in Venice and the area
of the Republic that served as the
ghetto geographically was previous
to that function a smelting area.
And so we like to think that, if
we're looking at positive aspects
of the ghetto, that it was a
melting pot of many, many ideas
and cultures coming together.
And such is the reality of today
as well where we have a melting pot
of many entities coming together
to bring you this program.
And so it's really my pleasure to
acknowledge the Embassy of Italy,
and you'll hear from our
esteemed Ambassador in a moment,
the Friends of the Law
Library of Congress,
and then the Hebraic Section of the
African and Middle Eastern Division,
the Italian Cultural Institute, and
the Primo Levi Center in New York,
all of which have a role
to play the programs
that the Library has been putting
on and will continue to put on.
We will have two speakers today,
Dr. Benjamin Ravid who's a
Professor Emeritus of Near Eastern
and Judaic Studies at
Brandeis University in Waltham,
Massachusetts, and Professor Dick
Schneider who is the Associate Dean
for International Affairs
and a Professor of Law
at Wake Forest University
in Winston Salem.
They will both be discussing
different aspects
of "Understanding Seclusion, the
Legal Dimensions of the Ghetto."
And so, without further ado, it is
truly an honor to introduce someone
who is no stranger to the
Library of Congress, our very,
very good friend, the Ambassador
from Italy to Washington, D.C.,
Armando Varricchio,
who, I have to say,
in addition to being the Ambassador,
and I think even more appropriately
for this morning, is
a Son of Venice.
So without further
ado, Your Excellency.
[ Applause ]
>> Armando Varricchio: Good
morning, good morning everybody.
Thank you very much, Dr.
Schaffer, my dear friend, Roberta,
for your very kind introduction.
It's always a pleasure for
me to be back at the Library.
Such a distinguished cultural
institution here in Washington.
The reason we're here today is
to debate, from a legal point
of view these days, one of the
most seminal events in history,
the creation of this place
where Jews were secluded.
And from the very, very name,
Venetian name of the foundry,
the name ghetto became
so familiar to us.
The reason why we're here
also, because this vantage spot
of a number of events that we are
hosting together with a number
of institutions, first and
foremost, the Library of Congress,
to commemorate the 500 anniversary
of the founding of
the Jewish Ghetto.
And I like very much
today's presentation title,
"Understanding Seclusion, the
Legal Dimension of the Ghetto."
I want to start -- all those
who have been so important,
instrumental, to make
this event possible.
Dr. Natalia Indrimi from the
Center Primo Levi in New York
for so generously sponsoring
tonight -- today's event.
There that is part of a
series of [foreign words],
the most serene republic of
Venice, an event where we're trying
to put together different arts,
different expression of culture,
and today's fits very, very
prominently into todays.
I would also like to
welcome our speakers
that have already been
mentioned, Professor Benjamin Ravid
and Professor Dick Schneider.
But today's central
theme, seclusion,
seems particularly
appropriate in this day and age.
Particularly today when we
look at the early history
of the segregated Jewish Community
in Venice and to showcase rare books
and documents for Library
of Congress,
collections related
to the Jewish Ghetto.
It's important to go through those
pages because we should never forget
that the ghetto, [inaudible]
and many
of the reasons why it has become so
important and prominent in history.
It's because at that particular
time it became a center for culture,
production of arts,
literature, music.
So while these people were really
forced into that small tiny place,
their bodies, their persons
were secluded, but their souls,
their minds, their spirits were
flying so high to be able to produce
so important base of
arts and culture.
But the ghetto, its
origin, it's history,
and what it has become today, are
so intertwined with the history
of Venice, a city which welcomed
Greeks, Turks, Armenians, Persians,
and probably not as exotic as all
those people, but Germans, too.
Inclusion and seclusion, a
city which gave protection
to minorities and, at the
same time, kept them separate.
This, of course, allows us
maybe to spend a few words
that I'm sure will be
spelled and elaborated later,
but important of the melting
pot, which has been mentioned,
the way we make sure, even
today, that different cultures,
different languages,
different religions,
different identities, can co-exist.
Incidentally, [inaudible]
first, with the performance
of The Merchant of
Venice in the Old Ghetto
which was either are
the two unprecedented.
I don't want to retrace
here the history
that led [foreign words] back
in 1516, the Doge of Venice
and Venetian Senate to
decree, to issue the decree,
that all Jews must
live together which,
an area which was both
enclosed and monitor.
What is important today
is to stress the fact
that the Jewish Ghetto Venice
is considered a pivotal point
of reference for Italian
Jewish life.
It is also the site where many early
Hebrew books were first printed,
and we can have -- see
displayed most important
and beautiful examples.
And as we stand here today,
in what is not only the
world's largest library,
but one of the Embassy's
long-standing [inaudible] industry,
I must also mention the wonderful
making Hebrew books in Venice.
There's an online exhibit,
the result,
ultimate multimedia platform
created by the Library of Congress
in Washington
and the Biblioteca-Archivio
Renato Maestro of Venice.
And these will enable
younger generation students
and the general public to access
unique pieces ranging from 1521
to 1862, respectively,
the years which the oldest
and the most recent Hebrew
manuscript kept in Venice date back
to and will be accessible
on a permanent basis.
But while we go through the pages
of those books, while we'll listen
to the importance of
Ghetto in history,
while we assess the
legal peculiarity,
because Venice was a state of laws,
so everything was done according
to laws of the time, we should also
think about our time, our presence,
and particularly, you know, these
days in Europe, in my Europe,
the importance of preserving
history and preserving identity.
When people struggle for identity
I think that we should never forget
that what we are today, what, as
Italians, as Europeans are today,
is because of what we
have been in the past.
And because of this unique
combination of different cultures,
of different histories,
of different religions,
so all of this has made our
part of the world unique.
And within the broader
perspective of the large Europe,
there was a tiny, tiny city.
I don't know whether
you [inaudible] to land
into Venice, and look from above.
You can see how tiny the
collection of islands is.
In those little part of Europe, a
city that was built not upon a hill
but on the water by people who
were trying to escape from fear,
from anger, the invaders were
arriving and they were --
tried to find escape and a new
shelter by taking the water
and building on this, and
you know, unhealthy piece
of small lands a new city.
Venice, as it has been in
history, as it is today,
would not have been the same
without what our brothers, the Jews,
had provided to the city with
their ideas, with a daily life,
with their businesses, with all
their activities that are pertaining
to be proud citizens of Venice.
So, as I said, for me, is also an
emotional moment to be here today
with you today, and I'm sure that,
as always, we'll never forget
that history is our teacher.
And when we're looking back and also
trying to understand how a democracy
of the time like Venice, according
to the laws, took that decisions
and made legal the Ghetto.
We should never forget that
laws are so important only
if laws can reflect a
human spirit, values,
and not simply make possible what
should never be made possible.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Roberta Shaffer: I would like
to just remind you before we begin
with the formal lecture
series, to please make sure
that your phones are silenced.
And now if you would not mind,
if you brought anything in,
please place it under the seat in
front of you, fasten your seatbelts,
and make sure that your
minds are in an open
and unlocked position [laughter]
so that we may time-travel back
to Venice 1516 together with, first,
Professor Benjamin
Ravid from Brandeis.
Professor Ravid, will you
please take the podium?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Benjamin Ravid: Well, good
morning, bongiorno, shalom.
To decide what to talk about
when it comes to the city
of Venice is a major
challenge because, you know,
there are over a hundred islands,
one of which, or two, one-and-a-half
of which, however you want
to define it, are the Ghetto.
There are decades,
centuries of history.
And I decided that really the two
best-known things about Venice --
one of them is fictional, the other
is reality, and I allude here,
of course, to Shylock
and the Ghetto.
Since my field is history
rather than literature,
I thought I should not
touch The Merchant
of Venice and rather
speak about the Ghetto.
Now, one reason why I
especially would like to speak
about the Ghetto is
because of a currency
that the word has in
everyday parlance.
I think every word, every
language, on the face of the globe.
I'm not quite sure what goes
on in a certain couple of areas
of the world I have absolutely no
wish to control over whatsoever.
I can't even recognize the word
if I were to see it written out.
But I think, certainly, when
it comes to the Western World,
you know, the word ghetto has
entered everyday parlance.
So I'd like to go back after
thanking His Excellency,
the Ambassador, for his wonderful
opening words, for Roberta Shaffer
for having invited me here,
for our friends who set
up the wonderful exhibition which I
think is very important in showing
that there was a Hebrew press,
that Venice was indeed the
center of the Hebrew press.
For the [inaudible] for her
excellent administrative work
in getting me here today.
And I'd to really now to turn
to something that's really been
bothering me for a long time.
Indeed, approaching half a century.
And I want to share this
concern with you today
because it involves not only our
understanding of Jewish history
and the position of the
Jews in the world, but also,
as I alluded to before,
developments in our time,
especially in the field
of urban sociology.
So I'm going to do this today
by considering the nature
of the early modern Italian Ghetto.
Now, my relationship with the
Ghetto began over 40 years ago
as I began my PhD thesis on a --
the topic of the Jewish
merchants of Venice.
I will not talk about them today.
I'll barely mention them.
That's another issue.
I came across the fact that in 1541
the Jewish merchants were required
to -- Jewish merchants
coming from the East,
Levantine Jewish merchants
complained
to the Venetian Government that
when they came to Venice to trade,
they did not have enough room for
their merchandise in the Ghetto,
which was too small for
them, and, therefore,
they requested additional
adequate place.
And the Venetian Government, always
attuned to the interests and needs
of commerce, gave them
an additional space
in which they were to confined.
That was known already
then as the Ghetto Vecchio.
So since the word ghetto was looming
in the very beginning of the story
of the merchants, I obviously had
to consider also -- I wanted --
I don't mean that I had
to -- it was necessary --
to also consider the Ghetto.
So the history of the
Jews of Venice,
as we look at their cultural,
their intellectual achievements,
the community that they
built based upon Jewish law,
the fact that they had virtually de
facto autonomy within the Ghetto,
et cetera -- for all of
the history of the Jews
of Venice the word
Ghetto is lurking in there
and survives down to the present.
So if we begin to investigate
the institution of the Ghetto,
the previous literature -- and
we're back now in the 1970s --
there seemed to be
a general consensus
that the word Ghetto first appeared
in Venice, but no consensus,
really, about its entomology.
Some saw its origin in a Venetian,
or at least Italian, source.
And others derived it more
fancifully from Jewish sources.
For example, the word ghetto -- the
word get meaning a bill of divorce
because the Jews were segregated
from society, et cetera.
And over the centuries, much ink
had been spilled tracing the history
of the word Ghetto, the
background before the Jews came
in to be confined to one.
Now, actually, the original meaning
of the word Ghetto was buried
in the writings of certain 17th
and 18th century Venetian
antiquarians and historians.
And today it's been established
beyond any shadow of doubt
that the word originated, as we
already heard today, in Venice,
in a copper foundry in Venice.
So, originally then, we have a
place called Il Ghetto, the ghetto,
that had been the site of the
Municipal Copper Foundry of Venice.
The main activity there had been
the production of bars of copper
and also the alloy of bronze
used to make cannonballs.
Il Ghetto, from the Italian root
[foreign word], to throw or to cast,
which we find surviving
today in English in words
such as eject, jet, trajectory.
Now, if you have a foundry you're
going to have waste products.
And waste products have
to be dumped somewhere.
So across from the ghetto, Il
Ghetto, was a sort of swampy island.
Remember, Venice was all --
much of Venice was swampland
that was gradually drained
and the piles were put down
and the city built on those --
the land claimed from swamp.
So, basically, the waste products
began being dumped on the island
across from the ghetto and what
happened was that that island
where things were dumped was --
became known as Ghetto Nuovo
because it was the new ghetto,
the expansion of the ghetto.
Whereas the old area that had
been the foundry area became known
as the Ghetto Vecchio.
So we have two areas functioning
in Venice called Ghetto.
One is the Ghetto Vecchio,
the original one.
Those of you who have been there --
I assume many of you
have been there, right?
Fast show of hands.
How are we doing?
Okay. So, remember, the Ghetto
Vecchio is on the mainland --
well, not on the mainland.
Mainland terra firma means,
you know, back in [inaudible].
It was on a very long island.
You can go across on the main
streets there from one river,
one canal, to the main
canal of Cannareggio.
And the new area on which
things were being dumped is the
Ghetto Nuovo.
Now, as the foundry of the
commune, which was producing cannons
and balls and the like, as in the
15th century, Venice was embarked
on expansion on the
mainland, terra firma.
That means, literally,
the main land .
Eventually reaching the
borders of Milan in the West.
Lombardi, Milan, whatever
you want to call it.
The ghetto could not produce enough
artillery and other things needed
for the army and, therefore,
the manufacturer of the bronze,
the cannon balls, et cetera, was
moved to the arsenal and the island,
the main land part, the island --
I'm sorry, the Ghetto Vecchio
on the main larger island
and the adjacent island of
the Ghetto Nuovo were sold off
and they became areas
which contained modest
two-story dwellings.
And we'll skip the details that
have all been reconstructed,
how they were divided up and
who owned them and the nature
of the housing, et cetera.
Now, as of then -- as of the
earlier days, and down to 1516
as the Ambassador, I
think it was, pointed out,
we have no Jews whatsoever
associated with the ghetto.
It's low and middle income,
probably more lower income housing,
mainly two stories, et cetera.
Now, the interesting thing is,
as I began reading on the Ghetto
and more important Jewish quarters
prior to this point of 1516
in the Middle Ages,
there was a major problem
in that the word ghetto was
frequently used to refer
to Jewish quarters prior
to 1516 which, obviously,
was a major anachronism, since
the word was not known outside
of Venice.
And, moreover, nobody would have
associated it in any way, shape,
form, and manner with the Jews.
Now, moreover, this word ghetto
was used by our contemporary,
our contemporaneous
historians to refer
to all types of Jewish quarters.
Sometimes Jews are living
in a segregated area.
mixed among Christians.
Sometimes Christians are living
in the supposed Jewish area.
As an independent variable
sometimes walls were erected,
sometimes they had gates.
Because, remember, those
turbulent days, for security,
areas were walled up, gates would
be locked at night, et cetera.
The main thing is that
almost always,
for all of these so-called Jewish
quarters, there was no reference
to any legislation or
edict establishing them.
And their origins, as a rule
-- there are a few exceptions,
and if you're aware of one of those
few exceptions, just delete it.
As a rule -- I'll deal
with one exception shortly.
As a rule, the origins of
when the Jews were settled
where they were are lost forever
in the mists of antiquity.
I should say lost forever
because we all know that thanks
to wonderful places like the Law
Library and Library of Congress
and preservation of books, we'll
never know what will be discovered
in terms of manuscripts
and books, et cetera.
But as of today, things are unclear.
So if we go back to the --
to Venice, if we read carefully
that edict of 1516, we will see --
actually, legislation of the
Senate to 1516 proclaimed
by the Doge establishing the ghetto
and the subsequent course of events,
we can conclude that the early
modern Venetian Ghetto was
characterized by three important
necessary characteristics.
First of all, it was compulsory.
Every Jew had to live
inside the Ghetto.
No exceptions.
Number two, segregated.
No Christians were
allowed to live inside it.
In fact, the Christians
had to move out
and the landlords were
granted a one-third increase
to be free from all taxes.
Very important.
I meant it was worth much more
than a third more in order
to get their tenants to move
out and the Jews could --
the Jews had to pay more.
Thirdly, the area was enclosed.
In other words, it was surrounded by
walls and a gate or gates that had
to be locked at night and remained
so locked until the morning.
So this then is the main
feature or features, if you wish,
of a ghetto -- compulsory,
segregated, enclosed.
Now during the counter-reformation
period
that usually is taken
that dates from 1555.
We'll stay out of the
problems of dating things.
Gradually compulsory
segregated and enclosed areas
of Jewish residents were established
in all the other Italian cities,
major cities with the exception of
Livorno, such as Rome, Florence,
Sienna, Padua, Verona, Mantwin
[assumed spelling], elsewhere.
Italian Jews are living
behind ghetto walls.
Based on the Venetian experience all
of these places were called ghettos
or, better in Italian, getti.
And, therefore, I'm proposing
that to the turrim [assumed
spelling] compulsory, segregated,
enclosed, be accepted
as a definition
of what an early modern
ghetto, Jewish ghetto,
Italian Jewish ghetto,
was to differentiate it
from subsequent quarters
often referred to as ghettos.
Now, with this definition of what
constitutes the original ghetto
in early modern Europe,
it should be noted
that the were a few
compulsory segregated
and enclosed Jewish quarters
in Europe before 1516,
primarily in Castile and Aragon.
Let me not talk more about that
because it will take up
too much of our time.
And most famously, of course,
was the Ghetto of Germanic Lands,
Imperial Center, Frankfort,
where the Ghetto of Frankfort,
established in 1464, would qualify
as a ghetto before
the word so to speak.
But these quarters were
never called ghettos.
They were only became called ghettos
after the end of the Venetian Ghetto
with the coming of
the emancipation --
that means the end of the 18th
century, the end of the 1700s.
The word ghetto began to spread.
And, for example, the segregated
compulsory enclosed Jewish quarter,
Frankfort, was always called the
Judengasse, the Jewish Suite.
Never called the ghetto
until after 1800.
The word began travelling northward.
So, therefore, in the very
felicitous formulation
of Robert von Pfiel, the city
of Venice retains the copyright
for the semantically innovative
term ghetto as defining the locus
of the settlement of
the Jews in the city.
So every Italian city,
with the one exception
as we said, Livorno, had a ghetto.
And I do not mention more about
Livorno today because you have one
of the world's leading experts on
the field sitting in the audience,
Bernie Cooperman, who is at
the University of Maryland.
An old friend from way, way back.
Now, one of the new
insights on the ghetto,
and this is something implied but
never quite absolutely realized,
is that no matter how many gates
and what hour they were locked at,
the ghetto was not
hermetically sealed,
and it was very, very porous.
And this has got to be
understood as the background
for Venice as a melting pot.
Not quite the melting pot as
a mixture of various peoples
from various backgrounds.
The ghetto was established, it
is true, to minimize contact
between Christians and Jews.
But the government only sought
to totally eliminate it at night
because the Christian authorities
feared that under the cover
of darkness all sorts of condemned
and forbidden relations
could very easily occur.
And their suspicion was
probably not without grounds.
During the day not only could
Jews freely leave the ghetto,
and Christians could enter at
will, but one group of Christians
in Venice was even compelled to
come into the ghetto and here --
this is most interesting
because from the very beginning,
or let's say a few months
after the very beginning,
the Venetian Government
insisted that the pawn shops,
which were the reason for which
Jews were allowed into Venice,
and which the government made
the Jews operate for the sake
of the urban poor, these pawn shops,
the reason that the Jews
were tolerated in Venice was
to be located in the ghetto.
So that meant that any Christian
engaging in money lending,
any Christian engaged in borrowing,
had twice to enter the ghetto.
Once to pawn his object and we hope
for his sake a second
time to redeem his pawn.
Furthermore -- this is
often neglected -- the --
given the topography of Venice and
the size and location of the ghetto,
it would be very inconvenient for
the Christian inhabitants of Venice
to reach their destination on
occasion if they could not cut
through the ghetto during the day.
And I'll digress for a minute
to show you how the most
unexpected sources dealing
with the most unexpected things draw
your attention to the commonplace.
A proposal was made in the
-- I think it was 1764 --
to establish a bullring in
the campo of the Ghetto Nuovo.
Now, I've never personally
measured it, and I'm not quite sure
if it's absolutely
correct because I can think
of a couple of other large campos.
But I remember reading
somewhere that the campo
of the Ghetto Nuevo was the second
largest, after San Marco, in Venice.
Whether it is or isn't, the
point is it really is large
and it is very convenient
for things.
Now, there were some
objections to this proposal.
And one of the objections was that
it would handicap the Christians
who wanted to pass through
the ghetto on the days
when it was closed
off for the bullring.
The bullring never went up.
There were no races
in the Ghetto Nuevo.
It's been used for all sorts of
things since the emancipation time.
Some of them -- I've never
personally been there
on movie night, but I'm
sure it's very pleasant
under a warm Venetian sky.
So, anyways.
The point is that Christians
were not strangers to the ghetto.
And the converse of this is
agreement day Jews could be outside
the ghetto freely and they could
associate with Christians and/
or introduce all aspects
of Jewish culture,
denuded of its Christian content --
that's worth really a talk
in itself -- into the ghetto.
Italian, or more accurately
Judeo-Venetian was the spoken
language of the Jews.
That's basically Venetian
dialect with a little Hebrew
and Aramaic coming in
from the prayer book
and the religious sources,
et cetera.
And the Judeo-Venetian
was the everyday language.
And the elite could
not only read Italian
but they also could write it.
So Jews are writing in
Italian, the vernacular.
And even in Latin,
because in Latin --
in Italy, Latin was not seen
as the language of the church,
but rather as a language of culture,
of the inhabitants of the republic
of letters and, therefore,
it was not considered
by the Jews to be taboo.
So we always then have to remember
that the term ghetto refers only
to the housing arrangements
of the Jews.
And their culture was
determined by their environment,
not by their housing arrangements.
And the nature of the community was
further determined by the nature
of the cosmopolitan city of Venice
which, as it was so well pointed
out by the Ambassador, and again,
there's another long theme.
You can discuss whether the laws
on the -- regarding the Jews were,
quote, fair, humane,
et cetera, or not.
By contemporary standards they
were certainly at least --
they were certainly very
favorable to the Jews.
But the key thing is that
everything was passed
by a council, by a legislative body.
The Jews had every right of appeal
and everything follows
the due process of law.
The one thing that one can
learn from studying Venice's,
that there were laws --
this is a lawful state
and everything is proceeding
on a legal basis
with committees sometimes one
feels maybe too many committees,
but that's another issue.
If you had a problem, you
established a committee.
They already realized
that back then.
And how often the committee
met, et cetera,
and all that is another problem.
But the point is this
is a law-abiding state.
Now, looking ahead to the 19th and
20th century, because I really want
to keep it moving, much
confusion arose as both past
and contemporaneous dense
areas of Jewish residents
that were neither compulsory
segregated nor enclosed came
to be referred to as ghettos.
It has been observed, in
fact, to the preliminary --
we're talking now about the
end of the 20th century.
It's certainly true today.
Still true -- preliminary views
of ghetto definitions reveal
that the ghetto was
probably the most misused
and misunderstood spatial
concept used by social scientists.
Clearly, the extended
use of the word ghetto,
in many different senses,
created a blurring
of the very important distinctions
between voluntary Jewish quarters
and those that were
segregated and closed.
These distinctions reflected
completely different attitudes
toward Jews on the part of
governments and societies.
Because of this blurring, modern
scholars have found it necessary
to distinguish between
different types of ghettos.
And I'll skip the details
on the terminology,
but we have technical ghettos
and nontechnical ghettos.
We have Louie Wirth, the great
sociologist of the Ghetto
of the Chicago School, Colin
[inaudible] using the term
of voluntary ghetto which
certainly would have been considered
oxymoronic by inhabitants
of the Italian Peninsula.
And so it goes to distinguish
between forced ghettoization,
self-ghettoization, et cetera.
Now, in this connection, we ought to
note that the 20th century ghettos
of Nazi Europe, which is where
most people acquire their knowledge
of what ghettos were, and as
Mitch Duneier demonstrated
in a recent book, had much to do
with popularizing the word ghetto
in the Afro-American world,
although it was known before that.
But it -- your [inaudible]
soldiers in the American Army
and Europe saw the Nazi ghettos.
These ghettos of modern Europe,
if the 20th century is
still considered modern,
differed fundamentally from those of
the early modern Italian Peninsula.
The Italian ghettos were supposed to
provide the Jews with a permanent,
clearly-defined space in
Christian society in accordance
with the traditional Christian
theology that the Jews were to live
in a subjected condition until
the second coming of Jesus.
This was to prove the rejection
of Christianity by God.
They're living under abject
circumstances until the Messiah came
to redeem all of humanity,
et cetera.
On the other hand, the Nazi
ghettos were very, very different
because they in no way had
anything permanent about them.
This was no way a permanent
settling of the Jewish problem
by providing them with a living area
because of their economic utility
in Christian society, but
rather once the decision
to embark upon the final
solution had been made,
the ghettos constituted
a temporary waystation
on the road to emancipation.
And these two different kinds of
ghettos reflect the difference
between traditional religious
anti-Judaism on the one hand
and modern racial antisemitism
in its ultimate form.
In the case of anti-Judaism
a Jew could escape the ghetto
by conversion.
There was a way out.
While in the case of modern
antisemitism, one could not escape
by one's own conversion nor by the
conversion of one's parents nor
by the conversion of less
than three grandparents.
So, interestingly the difference --
different natures of a compulsory
segregated and closed ghettos
of pre-emancipation Christian
Europe on the one hand and those of,
on the other hand, of Nazi-occupied
Europe, lead to the conclusion
that the experience of
European Jewry from 1940
to 1945 did not constitute
a return to the Middle Ages,
but rather constituted the advent
of a completely new
and far worse reality.
Indeed, the statement or
the remis-statement better,
that the Holocaust
represented a return
to the Middle Ages is probably
one of the most misunderstood --
one of the most widely spread
misunderstandings associated
with the word ghetto.
Now, to begin our descent to pick
up on Roberta's very apt analogy,
I see a story and I'm very bothered
by the use of the word ghetto
to describe a wide range of
Jewish quarters, let alone those
of subsequent current
application to the situation
of other minority groups,
whatever their nature.
And I hope that, after
a few more minutes --
I promise not more than a couple --
you, too, will share this concern.
The basic problem is as
one historian put it,
the word ghetto has lived
through more metamorphoses
than any other word with
such a long history.
So, when one hears the word
ghetto, one has to ask,
to which ghetto is the speaker
or author intending to refer,
and does the word invoke
the desired image?
If the compulsory segregated
enclosed Jewish quarters of Venice,
Rome, and Florence were ghettos,
if the Lower East Side of New York
and Whitechapel and wherever else
were ghettos, if Warsaw, Lage,
and Bialystok were
ghettos, if Westchester
and Newton are golden ghettos, what
exactly does the word ghetto mean?
Incidentally, ghettos
did not cease --
did not exist in pre-World
War II Eastern Europe.
The alleged ghettos
of Eastern Europe,
which should be called [foreign
word] or [foreign word],
and even the entire pre-World War
II, pre-World War I, palo-settlement
as a whole, cannot
accurately be called a ghetto
in the early modern Italian sense
because some Jews were allowed
to live inside it while --
outside it, while Christians
could live within it.
I haven't seen it for
many years, decades,
but I believe that in Fiddler
on the Roof you will
not see any ghettos.
Now, if our understanding
of the word is unclear,
how can our understanding
of the Jewish Experience be?
And when we speak of
non-Jewish ghettos in the cities
of North America, South Africa, and
elsewhere, what are we referring to?
Is it a compulsory area
established by the state
or by zoning laws or by redlining?
If it is compulsory, is it enclosed,
is it gated, is there a curfew,
is every person who is living in
that ghetto required to live in it
and no members of any
other community are allowed
to do in it -- live in it?
What image comes to our mind
when we hear the word ghetto?
We may or we will, probably,
encounter this important question
when we read the morning newspaper
or watch the evening news.
Now, clearly, the -- clearly,
the situation cannot be rectified
by a global change in every case
in which the word ghetto has
been used in print in the past.
What we can do, however, is use the
word ghetto with some explanation,
with some nuancing, and with a
full awareness of the problematics
of identifying a ghetto and
share this awareness with others,
that the word ghetto has
changed its meanings.
Now, it's all right if a
word changes its meaning.
But the problem is when the old
meanings are used simultaneously
and you have a pile of meanings
and they're all being jumbled
in together, and it's not clear
what the user is referring to.
It's unclear.
And our understanding of a
past also becomes very blurred.
So I'm suggesting to conclude
the differentiated use
of the word ghetto will lead
to a much better understanding
of a major feature of
both Jewish history,
of world history, and
-- I said both.
I should say all of -- never ad lib.
Either write that out and stick
to it or ad lab completely.
That will lead to a much better
understanding of a major feature
of Jewish history, world
history, and urban history.
If I may cite the titles of one of
my articles, that while originally,
while every ghetto
was a Jewish quarter,
not every Jewish quarter
was a ghetto.
May I put in one personal
word for 15 seconds?
Today marks for me a first time that
-- by which I'm greatly honored.
I refer to a few of the
speakers wo preceded me.
And I want to thank
everybody who came here today
and I have my dear wife
with me [inaudible].
But today marks a first in that
I have present not only my son,
but also my grandson, Ethan.
And assuming that he
has not left [laughter],
assuming -- yeah, he -- there he is.
He's smiling in the back.
So this is the first time I've
had the privilege of hearing --
of having Ethan in the audience.
And yesterday, when he went -- we
went around the Capital Building,
et cetera, he asked questions of a
guide in almost every place we were.
And the questions were so
good, that I'm going to step
down quickly before he gets to
ask me a question again today.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Roberta Shaffer:
We're next going to hear
from Professor Dick Schneider
about the Merchant of Venice ,
and as many of you know, this late
16th century Shakespearean play is
often categorized as
a romantic comedy.
And it is constantly being
alluded to in literature.
The Merchant of Venice had
been the subject of opera,
poems, novels based on it.
Recently a novel by Nadine
Gordimer mentions the Venice Ghetto
and The Merchant of Venice
in one of the chapters.
But I think even more fascinating
as a tribute to the longevity
and continuing influence of
this play, is first the face
that it was the subject of
three early silent films,
which I am sure are in the
collections of the Library
of Congress -- an English, a
French, and a German silent movie.
And then in a more contemporary
vein, quotes from The Merchant
of Venice have been peppered in
any number of Star Trek episodes.
So if we have any doubt of
Shakespeare's enduring legacy,
or the enduring legacy of
The Merchant of Venice ,
we have contemporary art
and culture to point to.
So without further ado, I'd like
to present Professor Dick Schneider
who teaches Law Literature
and Culture in addition
to his many other duties
at Wake Forest University.
Professor Schneider.
>> Dick Schneider: Hello, everyone.
Thank you very much
for having me here.
Thanks to Roberta and
Isabella and the whole staff
of the Library of Congress.
It's been really a pleasure to
work on this project as well
as the project which I'll
talk about in just a minute
which is the Mock Appeal of
Shylock coming up in June.
I'm going to take now the
fictional side of things
that Professor Ravid
put aside and the nature
of these remarks are going to
be completely different from his
because it's the difference between
somebody who's looking at something
as an aspect of literature and
philosophy as opposed to someone
who discusses something
as a matter of history.
Shakespeare was not writing history.
Shakespeare wrote a play.
And yet the play itself is based in
a profound understanding of history
and of the contemporary
nature of Venice.
Shakespeare, for instance, was
very sensitive to the fact that,
as Professor Ravid said, Venice was
a city of laws, a republic of laws.
It stood or fell on the basis of its
laws which is really at the heart
of The Merchant of Venice .
So, as you know, many
Shakespeare plays have seen kind
of post-historical kind of rewrites.
For instance, in the 18th
century, it's well known
that King Lear was performed
usually with a happy ending.
King Lear survived, and Cordelia
survived and they lived happily ever
after as father and daughter.
Hamlet was rewritten so that
Ophelia and Hamlet both end
up getting married and
live happily ever after.
It's interesting to me that
the rewrites of The Merchant
of Venice seemed to be clustered
in the last 20 years or 30 years
in this country because lawyers and
law schools apparently cannot get
over the guilt that they experience
at the conviction of Shylock.
And so we keep giving
Shylock a second chance.
And sometimes that second chance
works out and sometimes it doesn't.
It depends on the lawyers
and it depends on the judges.
These are the so-called
mock appeals of Shylock.
One difficulty I have is kind
of assuming a certain level
of knowledge that you have of
the play because what I'm going
to be talking about is
principally the play.
So I'll just -- in just
25 words or less, I hope,
just quickly remind you that
the play is about a Jewish --
you can call him a
banker or a usurer --
a Jewish money-lender who lends
money to the merchant Antonio
and instead of charging
him interest,
he charges him a pound of flesh.
And if Antonio's ships don't come
back, and the time of the payment
of the bond passes, Shylock has the
right in his contract and his bond
to demand a pound of
flesh from Antonio.
And so the heart of the play is
the working out of this drama,
will Shylock demand this?
Will he not?
He goes to court with the
contract out in front of him saying
that he should be given this
right to take the pound of flesh.
At the last minute, Portia
comes into the action
and in a sense saves
the day for Antonio.
She turns the tables completely
on Shylock, finds a way to kind
of vindicate the laws of Venice
and at the same time declare
that if Shylock takes
his pound of flesh,
that he better take
only a pound of flesh
and not spill any Christian
blood or he will be found
to have violated the Alien
Statute which requires the Republic
of Venice then to take
the life of the person
who shed the Christian blood.
So she completely turns
the table on Shylock.
And at the end of the play Shylock
has to forfeit all of his wealth
and he has to convert
to Christianity.
And he ends -- then end of Act IV --
there's still Act V, but at the end
of Act IV, he leaves the play,
you know, beaten and humiliated,
beaten metaphorically,
and humiliated,
and kind of crawls away basically.
So that's kind of quickly in a
nutshell what goes on in the play.
I was involved this past summer
with -- as the Ambassador mentioned,
there have been a lot of events in
Venice relating to the celebration
of -- or the commemoration of the
500th anniversary of the founding
of the Venice Ghetto in 1516.
Also, coincidentally,
it's the 400th anniversary
of the death of Shakespeare.
And so the University
of Venice, principally,
and the city of Venice last summer
mounted an incredibly wonderful
experience for everyone who was
there at the time, including me
and a class of law
students from Wake Forest.
We -- they did a -- as
the Ambassador mentioned,
they did a new production of The
Merchant of Venice in the Ghetto.
It's the first time The Merchant
of Venice had been performed
in the Ghetto, performed outside.
It was a remarkable production.
There was a book launching.
Howard Jacobson has recently written
a book which is kind of a rewrite
of The Merchant of Venice ,
called My Name is Shylock .
It's a wonderful book.
And I advise you to read that,
although I would say before you
read the book you should reread The
Merchant of Venice because the
book will not be very understandable
-- it will be much
more understandable
if you've recently read
the play or seen the play.
And, you know, it all culminated
with this mock appeal that we did
where Justice Ginsberg
came all the way to Venice.
She appeared -- she taught my class.
She's a wonderful, wonderfully
generous person that way.
I had known her from prior
encounters with her and so it was --
and that was an incredible
part of the experience.
But then, as I said, it
culminated with this mock appeal
where we had three lawyers
presenting arguments for Shylock,
for Antonio, and for Portia.
That was the really new part
of this particular appeal was
that we added a lawyer for Portia.
As I said, this has been done in
the past on several occasions.
The Bar, the city of
New York has done it,
the University of Chicago
has done it.
There have been other places where
we've had mock appeals of Shylock,
but nobody has done it with a
third lawyer representing Portia.
So that was a lot of fun.
We had five judges who
heard the arguments.
And at the appropriate time they --
we all retired and deliberated
about the outcome of the case,
which I won't talk about now.
That will be going
into too much detail.
But this is all going
to be re-enacted,
not with the same personnel, but
it will be re-enacted in spirit
on June 21 here at the
Library of Congress.
So I encourage all of
you to come if you can.
Justice Ginsberg will again
be the Presiding Judge.
I will again be a judge.
We have three lawyers to
represent the three parties.
And we have a Shakespeare expert
coming down from Columbia.
While the judges are deliberating
Jim Shapiro will be coming
down to talk to the audience as
we deliberate about the play.
And we hope to have some very
fine actors do very short readings
of Shylock and Portia's
great speeches in the play.
So I think it will be a lot of fun.
Now, let me get into
the into the kind
of the more substance of my remarks.
And I'm going to be approaching this
issue of Understanding Seclusion,
the title for today's two addresses.
As I said, from the
standpoint of fiction,
it's not a little bit
ironic that, you know,
perhaps the most famous Venetian
is a fictional character,
somebody who never existed, Shylock.
And, as I make these comments
about Shylock, though,
which are all in the way
of looking at possible ways
under the contemporary kind of legal
culture of Venice in 16th century
to defend Shylock, this is also
a way to understand seclusion
because defenses of
Shylock really looked
at from just a slightly
different angle become ways
to understand the seclusion
of the Jews in the ghetto.
So that's kind of a subtext
as I move forward here.
So one of the most interesting
things that has to be
at least talked about before you go
into one of these mock appeals is
which law do you use, right?
Do you provide a kind of
new case for Shylock based
on the Venetian law that
existed at the time?
Do you look at the English law
that Shakespeare would
have been very familiar
with as he was writing the play?
It's doubtful that
Shakespeare ever went to Venice,
although The Merchant of Venice
kind of provides a, you know,
a center of argument of
that because some people --
except that some people think that
Shakespeare did not write the plays.
It's possible that somebody
else went to Venice.
But that's a whole other issue.
But Shakespeare probably
did not go to Venice,
and so he's really writing in a
sense a critique of laws in England
and the legal culture in England
through the prism of
looking at Venice.
So he can distance himself from
being criticized in England because,
hey, I'm just writing
a play about Venice.
I'm not writing a play
about England.
So you could look at English laws
or you could look at 20th century
or 21st century human rights laws.
And that has been a
temptation of a number
of these mock appeals
as they've happened.
So, for instance, as I mentioned
this, the Bar, the city of New York,
a couple of years ago did
one of these mock appeals
and a guy named Daniel
Kornstein, who wrote a book called,
about Shakespeare and law,
called Let's Kills All the
Lawyers represented Shylock
and Floyd Abrams represented
Antonio.
So that was a lot of fun.
But just to give you
a flavor of some
of these more 20th century
arguments, Mr. Kornstein,
in his arguments, made
the following arguments.
That the Alien Statute raised
by Portia is unconstitutional
and denies equal protection.
That Shylock's due process
rights were violated
when the civil trial evolved
into a criminal trial.
That the penalties
leveled against --
levied against him constitute
cruel and unusual punishment.
And the order for Shylock to
convert violated his right
to exercise freedom of religion.
So, a lot of that, you can see,
is borrowed from our Constitution
and borrowed from human
rights documents
and human rights instruments
that have developed long beyond,
long after the 16th
century in Venice.
Floyd Abrams said,
"It would be a mistake
to examine the trial
court's decision
through the unforgivingly
politically correct lens
of contemporary legal
and social mores."
So there's this kind of -- I guess
I would say there's this kind
of subtext that you
can't look at these --
at this decision, this
conviction in the play,
from the time of the 16th century
and come up with human rights,
with valid human rights arguments,
that you have to move forward
and argue anachronistically.
So the purpose of my remarks
in the next few minutes are
to really take this play and
look at it from the standpoint
of what was the legal culture
in Venice and England which,
even though England was
a common law country,
Venice was a civil law country,
those two traditions
are quite different.
Nonetheless, the intellectual
culture
and the legal culture
was largely shared.
They were reading the same people.
They were thinking many of the same
thoughts even though they became
embodied in different laws.
And so I'm just going to
suggest some ways to vindicate
or to attack the judgment of
the court, vindicate Shylock
through looking at
contemporary concepts
and contemporary understandings
of legal culture.
So, first of all, I'll start off
with just some basic human
rights considerations.
Shylock has not been treated
before the court like a human being
in the full sense of the concept,
nor has he been accorded human
rights in his daily life.
These arguments have been
made, but as I've said,
not so much in the
context of the time.
Those idea -- so, Shylock is in at
least two senses, inhabits a world
that is quite different
from Antonio and the rest
of the Christian aristocracy
of Venice.
Because he is Jewish, he is
first subject to different
and more prohibitive laws.
He is not a full member of the
society in which he lives and works.
Second, as a physical
constraint of his being socially
and legally set off, he must
live in the Jewish Ghetto
where he is subject again to
harsh restrictions relating
to living conditions,
travel, and social relations.
Yet, notwithstanding
his different status,
he makes one of the
greatest speeches in drama
to assert his common
humanity with his oppressors.
And you all know this speech.
And I can't help but just read a
little bit of it just to remind you.
This is considered to
be, by many commentators,
to be Shakespeare's great, you
know, plea for human rights,
a plea for a common humanity.
So the fact that Shakespeare
makes this in a sense
in the play is the beginning
of proof that there was --
there were thoughts at the time
that Jews should not have
been treated like this.
So, Salarino asks Shylock
what he's going to do
if he takes the pound
of human flesh.
What's it good for?
And Shylock responds,
"To bait fish with all.
If it will feed nothing else,
it will feed my revenge.
He hath disgraced me and
hindered me half a million,
laughed at my losses, mocked
at my gains, scorned my nation,
thwarted my bargains, cooled my
friends, heated mine enemies.
And what's his reason?
I am a Jew.
Hath not a Jew eyes?
Hath not a Jew hands, organs,
dimensions, senses, affections,
passions, fed with the same
food, hurt with the same weapons,
subject to the same diseases, healed
by the same means, warmed and cooled
by the same winter and
summer as a Christian is?
If you prick us, do we not bleed?
If you tickle us, do we not laugh?
If you poison us, do we not die?
And if you wrong us,
shall we not revenge?
If we are like you in the rest,
we will resemble you in that.
Of a Jew wrong a Christian,
what is his humility?
Revenge. If a Christian wrong a Jew,
what should his sufferance
be by Christian example?
Why, revenge.
The villainy you teach me I will
execute and it shall go hard,
but I will better the instruction."
So a powerful comment.
It's often forgotten that what
Shylock is reminding the hypocrite
Christians is that he wants revenge.
And if he's like them
in other things,
he's like them in wanting revenge.
So Aristotle wrote in The Politics
about the impossibility for someone
to achieve his or her full humanity
when separated from
others in the city.
The text of Politics was
accessible in England and in Venice.
Aristotle famously described the
human being as a political animal.
He wrote that, "He who is without
a city by reason of his own nature
and not of some accident is either a
poor sort of being or a being higher
than man," meaning a god.
Clearly, Shylock is not a god.
He is like the man of whom Homer
wrote in Denunciation , "Clanless
and lawless and hearthless is he."
So it's important that
Aristotle fixes on this idea
of being separated from the
city based on his own nature
and not of some accident.
So here we have Shylock being
separated in the ghetto based
on his nature of being a Jew.
Alasdair MacIntyre,
interpreting Aristotle passage,
writes that "A human being,
separated from the polis,"
from the city, "is
thereby deprived of some
of the essential attributes
of a human being."
MacIntyre aligns Aristotle
with Homer and Sophocles
as early thinkers who believe
that, quote, "A human being
who is separated from his
social group is also deprived
of the capacity for justice."
He says that, according
to Aristotle, quote,
"Separated from the polis,
what could have been a human being
becomes instead a wild animal."
So there's this idea
that the nature --
that separation in and of
itself creates a lack of justice
in the separated population.
And, according to Aristotle, this
idea that there's a fallback to kind
of wild instinctual feelings instead
of being governed by
legal principles.
Shylock, being a political animal,
gets set off, exhibits the handicaps
of separation from other
members of the city of Venice.
He can be hardly expected to respond
justly in contract or in court
when he is not a full
member of the polis.
The explicit and implicit
violence of the penalty he includes
in the bond is understandable
given that he has been deprived
of the capacity for justice and
may be closer to a wild animal.
For an extreme example
of this outcome
of exclusion you can
take a look at Barabas
in Marlowe's Jew of Malta , right?
So a lot of -- it's
possible that Shakespeare --
there were a lot of --
several things involving Jews
that were happening in England
about the time Shakespeare
wrote The Merchant of Venice .
But one of them was that
Marlowe had had a great deal
of success writing
The Jew of Malta .
And Barabas is a very different
character than Shylock.
If the court in Venice were
forced to recognize the legal
and physical separations
suffered by Shylock
and its effects it might
begin a process of enquiry
into the justification for its
laws when applied the contracts
between Jews and Christians.
In any case, this might be an
approach to a kind of nascent idea
of a human right to a
quality of treatment.
So I'm putting together
Shakespeare's own speech,
which I just read to
you, and Aristotle.
All right.
On a slightly different topic,
Aristotle himself opens the door
to the judge acting justly.
What is the responsibility of the
Duke of Venice to answer justly,
to act justly, and not, perhaps,
just according to the laws.
Another very influential
Aristotelian text
in the Renaissance was
the Nicomachean Ethics .
In it, Aristotle writes that
quote, "When people dispute
with one another they find
refuge before a judge.
To go to a judge is to go to the
just, for a judge wishes to be,
as it were, the just
ensouled," close quote.
An effective counterargument
to using Aristotle to argue
for equality of treatment
might be that Aristotle --
so, also accept, accepted slavery.
As you know, there was slavery
in the Greek city-states.
And it's interesting that at this --
that Shylock also points out
the hypocrisy to the Christians
in The Merchant of
Venice of the fact
that they have slaves,
that they own property.
And so, therefore, he's
saying, "Why cannot I not
at the same time enforce my
contract for the pound of flesh?"
Okay. Michelle de Montagne,
the great French Philosopher
of the 16th century can also be
brought to bear to demonstrate
that there was a whiff of
tolerance in the air at the time
that Shakespeare wrote
The Merchant of Venice .
Montagne was available to the
educated and Shakespeare had access
to Montagne's essays as of 1580
when they were first published.
He could have read them in whatever
French he had available to him.
Of course, the essays became
fully available to Shakespeare
when they were published in
English translation in 1603.
But that was after the composition
of The Merchant of Venice .
The relations between The
Merchant of Venice itself
and Montagne are beside
the point here.
The point is whether at the
time it would have been possible
in Christian Venice to see
a way toward more tolerance
with respect to laws.
In fact, Montagne was at the very
beginning of the arc of toleration
that would eventually culminate
with the "Bill of Rights" in America
and the "Declaration of the
Rights of Man" in France.
His famous essay, Of the
Cannibals specifically purposes
to impress Europeans with
conflicting, but legitimate,
claims to knowledge in practice
exhibited by non-European peoples.
In the case of the
"Essay", it was Brazilians.
In John Florio's translation,
Montagne writes,
"Now to return to my purpose.
I find as far as I've been informed
there is nothing in that nation,
Brazil, that is either barbarous
or savage unless men call
that barbarism which is simply
not common to them, as, indeed,
we have no other aim of truth and
reason than the example and idea
of the opinions and customs
of the country we live in,
where is ever perfect religion,
perfect policy, perfect
and complete use of all things."
So Montagne's saying that we
have to look at other groups
through an understanding that,
just because they do something
differently from the way we do it,
doesn't mean that we have the
right to judge them or think
that what they're doing is in
some way inferior to what we do.
Could the judges in the case of
Shylock's arguments not exhibit some
of the toleration and humanism
Montagne evidences toward peoples
far from Europe?
Could toleration become
especially relevant
when Shylock's ultimate punishment,
forced conversion, is considered?
Okay. So, those are
[inaudible] broad human rights
and toleration ideas.
To go to the ghetto more explicitly.
Shakespeare never mentions
the Jewish Ghetto
in The Merchant of Venice .
This is one of the things that has
puzzled people who thought a lot
about The Merchant of Venice .
If it -- if Shakespeare
knew Venice so well,
why did he never mention the ghetto?
There's no answer for that.
Why did -- so, many -- the
question has entered into --
well, I already mentioned that --
has entered into a small controversy
over who wrote The
Merchant of Venice .
To the arguments noted above under
human rights, take for granted
that Shylock is being treated
differently and unfairly,
but do not describe in detail
the kinds of prohibitions
under which he would
have lived and worked.
So as Professor Ravid
mentioned, the ghetto was located
in the northwest part of the
city on two small islands.
The islands were linked to
the city by two small bridges,
always under guard by Christian
soldiers who were paid,
not by the city, but by the
inhabitants of the ghetto.
Residents of the ghetto could not
leave between sundown and sunrise
because the city closed the bridges.
Moreover, the other parts
of the ghetto were separated
from the water by high walls.
Finally, the Jews had to
pay the cost of two boats
that kept the ghetto
surrounded and under guard.
If the Jews left the
ghetto during the day,
they had to wear identifying
marks, yellow badges
or skullcaps during
their stay in the city.
In addition to the requirement
to live in the ghetto and abide
by its exclusions, Shylock and all
other Jews in Venice faced frequent
and significant taxation
as well as a large number
of government economic regulations.
They could not engage
in numerous trades.
They were prohibited from
engaging in numerous trades.
And limited to particular
trades like pawn shops,
second-hand clothes,
and money lending.
The Catholic Church
prescribed some of the --
proscribed some of this activity.
So the Venetian economy needed
the participation of the Jews.
That was the deal.
The Jews could live in
Venice in the ghetto
if they provided those services.
So it should be obvious
at this point that there's
at least one strong reason for
Shylock to insist throughout most
of the trial scene on
repayment of his bond.
This is an individual who has very
limited rights and the according
of those rights to him are
all beyond his control.
The city determines
what Shylock may do
and what he's prohibited from doing.
From physical movement to
business occupation to the conduct
of commerce, Shylock is constrained.
Here in The Merchant of Venice he
at last possesses a piece of paper,
a contract, a bond, that
seems to give him some rights.
Can he be blamed for
reading it with blinders,
ignoring the larger context of
discrimination that Portia brings
so dramatically to bear when she
argues her case under the Alien Act?
Should the court be so quick to
condemn the expressive nature
of Shylock's small page of freedom?
So, I'm arguing that Shylock has a
desire to express his own yearning
for freedom through the
insistence on the bond.
And now the symbolism
behind the penalty.
Shylock argues that his
motive in signing the bond
with Antonio was not to seek
the life of any citizen,
even though the bond called
for the pound of flesh.
Motive must be important -- so
this is under the Alien Act --
motive must be important
because otherwise it's possible
than an alien doctrine, including a
Jew who helped a Venetian citizen,
could come under the law.
Likewise, an alien who accidentally
causes a Venetian to fall
and cut himself could be
prosecuted under the law.
So motive is important.
But there's a better,
more compelling argument
that I don't think has been raised
anywhere else in the literature
on The Merchant of Venice .
I would argue that the motive behind
the particular penalty demanded
by Shylock, the pound of flesh, is,
in fact, a proxy or a symbol of life
in the ghetto, and more
incisively, of the ghetto itself.
The ghetto is cut out of the body
of the city of Venice and exists
within it, but separately.
The pound of flesh, once removed,
interrupts the smooth functioning
of the human body just as the
distinct physical separation
of the ghetto interrupts the
continuity and the flow of Venice.
So, Dr. Ravid was talking about
the need for Christians to be able
to cross the ghetto, to come and go.
The ghetto interrupts
that natural flow.
Shylock is showing Antonio and the
rulers of Venice through his ruse
of the pound of flesh just what the
ghetto's separate status is doing
to Venice and to the
Jews who are forced
to live there in relative isolation.
This possibility is supported
by two historical references.
First in 1516 the decree
that created the ghetto
when the Venice City Council order
the Jews to leave other parts
of Venice and move into the ghetto.
It declared that the Jews
had to be removed [speaking
in foreign language] which
means they had to be removed
from the body of the city.
So Shakespeare had a ready metaphor
in the legal document itself
that created the ghetto.
Second, the contemporary of
Shakespeare who travelled in Italy,
including Venice, and published
a kind of travelogue in 1611
about those adventures and
many others, spoke of the Jews
who could quote, "flay many
a poor Christian's estate
by their griping extortion,"
close quote.
Of course Shakes wrote The Merchant
of Venice earlier than 1611,
but this line opens the possibility
that people at the time thought
of the extraction of
wealth from another person
as a kind of skinning or flaying.
The relation to the pound
of flesh is obvious.
Related expressions today
might include skinflint
or the skin off my back.
Okay. And just a couple of more
quick comments about defenses
that could be made for Shylock.
There's the idea of "the other."
Of course this is an idea which is
pursued mostly in the 20th centuries
through a philosopher named
Emanuel Levi Nau [assumed spelling].
And I'm not applying this 20th
century idea to The Merchant
of Venice , but what I am saying
is that if you look at Shylock
through the lens of being the other,
though a great deal becomes clear
in the play, and so I think
in that sense it's appropriate even
though the philosophy itself might
not have been in existence
at that point.
Shylock is fighting back
against marginalization,
against this othering.
He fights back through his
negotiation of the bond with Antonio
and through his conduct
during the trial.
But he cannot overcome his
fundamental invisibility
to the Christian forces
aligned against him.
First, the negotiation of the bond.
Shylock needs to bond to be an
affirmation of his own being.
As noted above, it has an
expressive side wholly apart
from its legal nature.
Shylock wants to be noticed and
wants his message to be understood.
At the same time, however, the bond
and its penalty may be a
significant weakness for Shylock.
I earlier alluded to
Shylock's famous Act III speech
with what I read where he seeks
common ground with Christians and,
in particular, with
respect to revenge.
Revenge is often overlooked
and underplayed in discussions
of the speech when a commentator's
emphasizing Shakespeare's empathy
and compassion for Jews.
As Shylock says, "If you wrong
us, shall we not revenge?"
What I want to focus on is
Shakespeare's use of the word wrong.
What is Shylock speaking about?
A legal wrong or a moral wrong
or just a semantic wrong?
If a legal wrong, then we do
not question Shylock's recourse
to the legal system.
But if he's speaking about a
moral wrong, and the speech
as a whole is overwhelmingly
about moral wrong,
then Shylock's own moral failing is
that he's using the legal
system to obtain revenge.
Bassanio in the very next scene
calls attention to the problem
when he says, quote, "In law,
what plea so tainted and corrupt,
but being seasoned with a gracious
voice, obscures the show of evil?"
So, Bassanio knows that law can
dress something up that is corrupt,
can make it seem to be acceptable.
Finally, during the
trial scene in Act IV,
Shylock shows his profound blindness
to his own failing when he says,
"What judgment shall I
dread doing no wrong?"
He cannot see the wrong that
he does to the legal system
by making it an accomplice for
revenge notwithstanding his desire
to make his bond an
instrument of descent.
So in the process of his trying
to overcome his othering,
he makes other mistakes,
certainly category mistakes.
Okay. And then two more points.
Next, Shylock's conduct
at the trial.
Fundamentally, even though Shylock
abides by the rules of the court,
he does not submit himself fully
to the forms of argument expected
by his adversaries or by the Duke.
So, at least within the construct of
the play as shown by Quentin Skinner
in his book, Forensic
Shakespeare --
it's a really wonderful book
about taking apart several
of Shakespeare's plays and
looking at them from the standpoint
of rhetoric and forensics that
were available in the Renaissance.
That the Duke and Portia
expected a very particular form
of argumentation from Shylock.
They did not get it.
The expected argument would
attract the rhetorical prescriptions
of classical authors such
as Cicero and Quintillion.
Skinner argues that Shylock, by
straying from the prescriptions
of classical rhetoric,
hurt his own case.
If Shylock does not adopt the
expected rhetorical strategies,
is he instead using
argument in ways attended --
intended to call attention
to his status as other?
Specifically, how much was
Shylock's rhetoric a product
of his own Jewish philosophy and
forms of Talmudic argumentation?
Was the ruling against Shylock
delivered in part out of a failure
to grasp the difference between
Western forms of argument
and Jewish forms of argument?
Without attempting anything more
than suggestion at this point,
I would direction your
attention to a work
such David A. Frank's
article, "Arguing With God,
Talmudic Discourse and
the Jewish Countermodel."
Frank argues that the Jewish
form of argument is founded
on freedom rather than necessity.
He opposes the Jewish act of
argumentation, the classical forms
of debate, that depend rather on
apodictic reasoning or reasoning
that goes to a clear certainty, a
standard that forecloses discussion.
Frank quotes two writers
on rhetoric and says,
"Recourse to argumentation assumes
the establishment of a community
of minds which, while it lasts,
excludes the use of violence."
But Shylock is read --
so my argument reverses
the traditional reading
of the trial scene where Shylock
is read as advocating violence,
the penalty, and Portia, mercy.
However, the violence of the
decision and sentence happen
because they're moving toward
a conclusion, in Western style,
that is, inevitably, with closure,
when Shylock must surrender his
wealth and convert to Christianity.
No one will ever be able
to show whether Shylock
would have shown mercy
to Antonio had he won his case.
Perhaps the point would
have been made
and the discussion could
continue with mercy in the offing.
Ins other words, that Shylock
was arguing from a point
of open-endedness rather
than closure.
Okay. I'm going to skip over some
of this, and I just want to get
to one final thing
which is from Bocaccio.
So this is an argument
focused on the systemic failure
of the Venetian state to take
into account the Jews
and their perspective.
Shylock and the Jews
had no role in debating
or adopting the laws
enforced by the court.
Is it equitable to have those laws
applied cruelly and exactingly
to those excluded from the polis?
In the Nicomachean Ethics
Aristotle wrote that
"what is called judgment in
reference to which we assert
that people are sympathetic
judges and have judgment,"
is the correct decision
as to what is equitable.
Madonna Filippa in
Boccaccio's Decameron ,
written in the 14th century,
articulated very clearly the
principle that is not equitable
to hold one group, in her case,
women, accountable to laws
that have been adopted without
their participation or contribution.
In the case at issue, Madonna
Filippa is accused of adultery,
but she argues that,
quote, "Every man
and woman should be equal before the
law and laws must have the consent
of those who are affected by them.
These conditions are not
fulfilled in the present instant
because this law only applies to us
poor women who are much better able
than men to bestow
our favors liberally.
Moreover, when this law was made,
no woman gave her consent to it,
nor was any woman ever so much
as -- even to much as consulted.
It can, therefore, justly be
described as a very bad law."
So there was a very
strong historical argument
at hand for Shylock.
Boccaccio was well
before Shakespeare wrote,
and Shakespeare knew Boccaccio
-- one -- knew his writing.
One has only to replace women in
Madonna Filippa's speech with Jews.
And, by the way, Madonna
Filippa was acquitted
of all the charges brought
against her [laughter].
So, I urge you all to come
to the mock appeal in June
and see how this works
out yet again.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Roberta Shaffer:
Thank you all very much.
We are going go have a brief
Question and Answer period,
but I would be entirely remiss
if I didn't acknowledge the
third intellectual giant
who is not physically on the
podium with us this morning,
but who is nonetheless
pervasive throughout the program.
And that is Nathan Dorn,
the Curator of Rare Books
at the Law Library of Congress.
Nathan organized the panel.
He organized the display with our
wonderful colleague Ann Brenner.
And he also is the person who
created the wonderful postcard book
that all of you should have
received as a favor today.
And so, before I bring Professor
Ravid and Professor Schneider back
to the podium to answer your
questions, I would please ask you
to join me in giving Nathan
a resounding applause.
[ Applause ]
And now members of the
Library staff have microphones.
I must remind you that our program
is being videotaped and that
if you do ask a question
you will likely be captured
on the video tape.
And if that's an issue for you
then our speakers will be here
after the program for you to
ask them a question privately.
So if Professors Ravid and
Schneider will rejoin us here,
we'll take questions from the
audience and then I know many
of you have to leave,
so I remind you
that at 2 o'clock we'll be
showing the movie, the documentary
about the Venetian Ghetto
right here in this room.
And there's a wonderful cafeteria
just behind us if you need
to refresh yourself in-between.
So please join me.
>> Benjamin Ravid: I
am good, good, good.
Thank you.
>> I'd like to know whether
ghettos were prone --
since they were solidified
Jews, whether they were prone
to attack rather than protected.
Were they closed off at night in
order to avoid carnal relations?
I believe the Pope
specifically objected
to carnal relations [laughter]
between Jews and non-Jews.
The very fact that The Merchant
of Venice has that title is
because Jews -- wasn't it because
Jews were forbidden to participate
in any guilds or to own land
in most of that time period?
And, finally, weren't
ghettos such as the one I saw
in Paris not allowed to expand
outward, but only upward
so that there was very closed
and crowded conditions?
Thank you.
>> Roberta Shaffer: Thank you.
I think, Professor Ravid,
that is more your question.
>> Benjamin Ravid:
Well, well, I'm sorry.
My short-term memory is going,
but let me try to remember some
of the points that you asked.
Number one, there are
many kinds of merchants.
You have merchants who are
engaged in local trade.
You have merchants who own stores.
You have merchants who engage
in long-distance trade.
You have merchants who
engage in maritime trade.
And I very -- in one lecture, indeed
I speak about the Jewish merchants
of Venice because Venice
specifically welcomed Jews
who can gauge in long-distance
maritime trade.
And as I've shown, one of
the greatest department --
the departures in Venetian law
was allowing former marranos
who had been -- that is
Jews who in -- Christians --
Jews who had been baptized as
Christians to revert to Judaism
in violation of canon law and to
instantly be allowed to engage
in the [inaudible] trade
which Christians --
for which Christians normally had
to wait 25 years before
they could do it --
because of the economic
necessity for Jews to help
out international Jewish
merchants, [inaudible],
many of them to help Venice
with its declining commerce
for various reasons.
So I think we have to differentiate
between various kinds
of -- of merchants.
And I would say that at the
time Shakespeare wrote his book,
the Jewish merchants in
Venice had just been given
that unique charter allowing them
to convert, allowing converted Jews
to revert to Judaism openly in
the ghetto which, fortunately,
had been burnt in Rome, and
they would have been allowed
to immediately engage in
trade with the Levant rather
than waiting for 25 years.
So when we talk about
Jewish merchants we have
to ask what kind of
Jewish merchants.
And, ironically, moneylending at the
time Shakespeare wrote his Merchant
of Venice was no
longer entirely --
there was no longer at all the
provenance of individual Jews
but rather the Jewish
community ran loan banks
that operated lending money under
government control at the low rate
of 5% which was economically
unviable.
So if anybody was the
Jewish merchant of --
if anybody was a merchant of Venice
at the time Shakespeare wrote
the play, you could make the case
that it was equally the Jews.
Moneylending is something else.
It was so stereotyped, erroneously.
Italian Jewish moneylending was
really small-scale pawn-brokering
for the sake of the urban poor.
I'm sorry, could you give me a
couple of the other questions again?
>> Roberta Shaffer: She
asked about the violence.
Was there violence?
>> Punished for leaving --
>> Benjamin Ravid: Sure.
>> Were they punished for leaving?
Were they punished
for leaving at night?
>> Benjamin Ravid: Oh
yes, absolutely, yes.
>> Would you address the
Pope's refusal [inaudible] --
>> Benjamin Ravid: Well, I'll tell
you, I'll tell you, I'll tell you --
>> -- between Jews and non-Jews?
>> Benjamin Ravid:
Well, I'll tell you.
I'd rather stay out of the Popes
today, but I'll be happy to talk
with you about that later
since we're sticking to Venice.
>> Excuse me.
Are you still talking about
different kinds of trades
and not the fact that Jews
were not allowed to participate
in owning land or joining guilds?
>> Benjamin Ravid: Jews
were forbidden by law
to own any land anywhere in
the Venetian state as of 1443.
Jews -- it was not necessary
to have a law forbidding Jews
from joining guilds because the
guilds were so Christian in nature
with Christian services,
Christian initiations in chapels
and what have you, that you did
not need a law that no Jews may --
de factor -- the Jews
did not join the guilds
and Jews had their own
separate but -- separate guilds.
There was one thing that
the Jews were allowed to do
and that was the sale
of second-hand goods
which were very important back
then in the pre-industrial age
because everything had
to be made by hand.
So furnishing them rugs and
clothing et cetera was custom-made
for the individual who ordered it.
Jews had a major role in that trade.
Jews had their own guild
of second-hand dealers.
Now the Pope set the
rules supposed --
the Pope did not legislate
for anywhere outside of Rome.
Each country, each country
-- and we call Venice,
Florence, Milan countries.
Each one of them had
their own government.
And in Venice the church
did not legislate.
The government legislated.
But the government happened
to be a Catholic government
so the government did accept much
of the general Christian
legislation on the Jews.
Technically speaking, the
Jews in Venice came eventually
to wear red hats and the Levantine
Jews only apparently were --
no, I'm sorry.
The native Jews of Venice
were wearing red hats, yes.
And the Levantine Jews
were wearing yellow.
So we have two colors
going systematically.
So if we're talking about Venice
and the government of Venice,
let's forget about the Pope unless
we're talking about a comparison
between the traditional
demands of Christianity
and their implementation by the
secular rulers in every country,
because they enacted the laws.
Okay, I'm sorry.
The, the --
>> Roberta Shaffer: Let's let see
if Professor Schneider has anything
to say and maybe move on because
we're a little constrained by time.
>> Dick Schneider: Yeah.
I was just saying that at
the heart of The Merchant
of Venice is the romance
between Jessica and Lorenzo.
So, you know, there's
the Christian and the --
and Shylock's daughter, Jessica.
And so, you know, Shakespeare
certainly gets us into that issue
of carnal relations
between Christians and Jews.
>> Benjamin Ravid: Sure.
>> One may --
>> Roberta Shaffer: Do we
have some other -- I'm sorry.
We have some other questions.
We'll take these two.
>> Hi. Yeah.
I'd like to -- if you can talk a
little bit more about the context
in which -- at the time
the ghetto was established.
Was anything going on in
particular in the early century
that would cause the city of
Venice to establish the ghetto?
>> Benjamin Ravid: Basically,
basically Jewish moneylenders had
been expelled from Venice in 1397.
They could only return
for 15 days at a time.
But there was a war on the
Venetian mainland known as the War
of the League of Cambrai
in which much
of Europe was organized
against Venice.
There were Jews on
the Venetian mainland,
Padua [inaudible] et cetera,
who were moneylenders.
They fled into the city of Venice
across a lagoon, into Venice itself.
They were supposed to go back home.
They argued, "We can't.
Our houses are destroyed."
They were in Venice.
They suggested that the
Venetian government let us stay
because we can lend money
and we can give you loans.
And the government said okay.
And that's what led the Jews in
1513 to be allowed to stay in Venice
on the basis of a charter.
However, the government tried.
Realized it was not appropriate for
Jews to be living all over the city.
Fifteen-fifteen, an
attempt to confine them
to a segregated area did not pass.
Fifteen-sixteen, it did.
So I would say that the
ghetto in one sentence
that the ghetto was a compromise
between having the Jews living
freely all over the city
or expelling them once
more as they had in 1397.
And it decided because of the
economic utility of the Jews,
it would allow them to stay.
But they had to be segregated.
That was the deal until
the end of the republic.
>> Roberta Shaffer:
Professor Schneider,
do you want to [inaudible]?
I think we have one more --
oh, okay, two more questions.
One right here and
then one in the back.
And then we'll invite you
to return at 2 o'clock.
>> Hello. Professor
Schneider, you were --
I sense you're avoiding this, but
I'm going to ask it to you anyway.
In the '30s a famous Jewish
scientist named Sigmund Freud wrote
a paper, a classic paper,
that there was no Shakespeare.
It was the Earl of Oxford.
Because Shakespeare never
left England and so a lot
of people wrote papers on this.
And I see you were sort of talking
about that as a controversial issue.
Do you know anything about
the antisemitism of people
in that period, the Earl
of Oxford and others?
That caused the creation of
that play and the point also
that if you're a playwright you can
see things and get away with it.
And so he didn't probably want
his name up there so he made
up the name Shakespeare [laughter].
>> Dick Schneider:
Well, I mean I'm not --
I would say if there's
a Q&A in June,
you should ask Jim
Shapiro that question.
He will, first of all be angry
but then he'll answer
the question [laughter].
No, I don't really -- I don't want
to get into the authorship issue
because that's just
such a huge issue.
But I would say that, you
know, apart from the Jew
of Malta being very
popular and it is --
people do question whether
Shakespeare could have written the
plays because of -- he
didn't go to this place,
he didn't go to that place,
he didn't read this language,
he didn't read that language.
But I'm personally convinced that
Shakespeare was one of those kinds
of absorptive geniuses who
didn't have to do a lot of things
that other people have to do
in order to capture a place
or a people or something like that.
That he was just -- that was the
part of the nature of his genius.
The other thing that was
going on with respect
to the Jewish relationships
at the time was there was a very
famous trial involving the personal
physician of Queen
Elizabeth who was Jewish.
And there was an allegation
that he was involved
in a spy plot against the crown.
And so -- and basically it became
a show trial and he was beheaded.
And so this was --
this brought attention
to the Jewish plight because,
you know, the Jews were kicked
out of England in the 13th century.
And so they were not allowed, you
know, there were very few, you know,
Jews that Shakespeare would have
really come in contact with, if any.
So there were things going on at
the time that maybe brought this up.
But the subject allowed him --
you know, the thing that's --
that obviously is ironic and
very -- well, ironic for us,
but not for them at the
time, is that, you know,
The Merchant of Venice
is a comedy.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Dick Schneider:
It's not a tragedy.
You know, we tend to think of
it as a tragedy because of the,
the way Shylock is treated.
But it was a comedy
because it ended happily.
He converted to Christianity.
What better result could there be?
And so, you know, it's a very --
it's a difficult thing for
us to put ourselves back
into that time, but I was just --
>> Roberta Shaffer: We'll take
our final question in the back.
Please wait for the microphone.
>> Thank you.
I have a question for
both of you [inaudible].
Prior to 15th century you mentioned
that the [inaudible] Vecchio,
which was producing
bronze and other things
for armories was moving
to the mainland.
At that time where the Jews
involved in the production
of [inaudible] armories and bronze.
And if that is the case, did
they move also to [inaudible]
to other places along with this?
And if that is the case, was
the law, the Venetian law
of excluding the Jews into the camp,
came after that, after that period.
That is something which
you may reflect on or --
my understanding may be wrong.
Professor Schneider, I have -- when
I started Shakespeare [inaudible],
the idea was from the
social point of view --
how much greed was there
with the moneylenders?
The way we understood that play was
-- there was a very big [inaudible]
and that was how it was
being portrayed and even
at a later stage antisemitism
was building
on such anti-Jewish greed that came.
Now your excellent presentation --
in fact, I am looking from the other
point of view, the revenge point
of view, within the
context of the Venetian law.
And then now that I -- there is
a revised play, is this revising
or giving us different
perspective of revenge in the plays
that you mention in June.
Would that make us understand
the other side of the story?
Thank you.
>> Dick Schneider:
Do you want me to --
>> Roberta Shaffer:
Why don't you go.
>> Dick Schneider: Yeah.
I didn't go into the question or
the controversy or the discussion
of whether The Merchant of
Venice is a specifically
anti-Semitic play.
I mean, that's something
that a lot of people --
you know, using the
speech that I read,
people point to that
and say, well, no.
Shakespeare's writing a play
that in a sense ennobled the Jew
and ennobled Shylock so
that we can see, you know,
and feel more sympathy when he's
convicted and forced to convert.
Other people argue no, that
he is adopting stereotypes
and using the Jew just for dramatic
effect and that it's, in fact,
you know, an entirely anti-Semitic
play because of the fact that it is,
you know, it ends happily from
the standpoint of the Christians,
that he successfully
silenced Shylock.
They managed to clear the decks of
his legal claim and save Antonio
in a way that doesn't seem to
shed any real negative consequence
on the Christian community.
So there's a real debate
about, you know,
whether the plan is
anti-Semitic or not.
I think that, from the standpoint --
you know, another part of the answer
to the question is that
this play has really been --
the production history of
this play is fascinating.
And after World War II, you know,
many places will not produce the
play because of the fact that it has
such resonance now, given
what happened under --
with the Holocaust and
the fate of Jews in Europe
and in other parts of the world.
So, it's something that has actually
made the play more sensitive
to people, which is part of the
reason that I think, you know,
that the trial, the
appeal that we have
in June will be very interesting,
whether we'll answer
these questions.
I mean, that partly -
I mean, one of the ways
that you can answer the legal
side of it is to look back
at the Venetian laws and say, would
it have been acceptable or legal
for somebody to demand a pound of
flesh instead of an interest rate?
And for that you really
need a lot of expertise
in contemporary Venetian and
civil, you know, Roman civil law.
But so I don't think we're
going to go down that route,
particularly on the actual interests
and the usury and that
kind of thing.
But I do believe that the
appeal will shed a lot of light.
And I think Jim Shapiro's talk will
also address some of these issues.
So I don't know if that's
an answer, but okay.
>> Roberta Shaffer:
[Inaudible] quickly.
>> Benjamin Ravid: Yeah, yeah.
I would give a very, very resounding
yes echo to what you said,
that the issue is not
so much Shakespeare
but rather what later
generations saw in it.
Very, very briefly, it's been
argued that an anti-Semite,
a real anti-Semite -- or we should
use the word anti-Jew, anti,
anti-Judaism because -- and the
word anti-Semitism shouldn't be used
before the concept of Semitism
came up and all that and so on.
And the problem in Shakespeare's day
was the problem of the Jew religion
and the religion you could
say to yourself by conversion
and Shylock's conversion was seen
as said as a victory for Catholicism
and also was seen as
being good for Shylock
because by converting he would
be saved on the Day of Judgment.
So converting to Christianity was
something that Christians also saw
as benefitting the immortal
soul of the Jew who had not gone
to Purgatory as a result.
The reaction of the Jew is
another thing [laughter].
Now I think it's -- I think
the problem is that the image
of Shylock became the
image of the Jewish usurer.
And the key thing is the portrayal
of Shylock on the stage, you know,
does he have a big hooked
nose and hunched over
and the way he pronounces things
in the Eastern European Yiddish type
accent which was un -- relative --
almost unknown in Venice.
How you portray him, how is it the
play directed indicates whether it's
anti-Jewish/anti-Semitic or not.
Had Shakespeare even a really
anti-Jewish we would have had more
Jewish figures in his plays and they
all would have been nasty bad Jews
because the anti -- the
real anti-Semite usually --
or anti [inaudible] will point
to negative aspects of
the Jews everywhere.
So that's one.
Number two, regarding Jews
moneylending, et cetera --
the word moneylending
-- the word bankers --
forget it except for
maybe the Rothschilds.
Moneylending is not always accurate
because Jews very often were limited
to pawnbroking and in
the case of [inaudible]
and the low rates of interest.
This might cause anti-Judaism for
the very simple reason that just
as we do not like our
credit cards and our banks,
when they say you missed a payment,
or you didn't pay everything,
therefore you'll pay 18%
a year, and, therefore,
we say expletive deleted you,
because we do not like our bank --
they charge us the penalties, they
charge us interest rates, et cetera.
So you -- it is a pleasure to be
able to borrow money that helps you.
Returning money does not help you.
So even if the Jews
are only paying --
only charging decent
rates of interest,
that leads to sentiments
against the Jews.
That combines with
Christian anti-Judaism
because their religion is off.
Combines with the dislike
of the perceived oppressor
who is charging high interest rates,
et cetera, allegedly high rates.
But you have to return anything --
if you're borrowing, you need money.
So returning more than
you borrow, returning --
but borrowed is hard enough.
Having to return interest
on top of it is even worse.
That plus racial anti-Semitism
is another component.
So that strengthens the
argument that the question is,
how is the play directed
and what is a view of it?
So I would come down on the
side the play's not anti-Jewish.
Is that wonderful quote that you
gave, the context of the times --
anyways, okay, thank you
very much [laughter].
>> Roberta Shaffer: So rather
than ending on expletives,
let's end extraordinarily and
give a very, very large round
of applause [applause] to Dick
Schneider, Benjamin Ravid,
and Nathan Dorn and the
Library's, small library staff.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.